all right don't try to make too much out
of it it's doing your job
[Applause]
right it's time for one of the great
segments that we do it is called did his
job i think it's so appropriate where
we're gonna start with this one zach
wilson all the buzz he had coming out of
the preseason but he had the new england
patriots a place where this segment
began did they do their job in the
second day absolutely in the secondary
they did their job they had four
interceptions jc jackson was tremendous
he had two interceptions oh yeah and if
you just saw these guys flying around
making plays confusing them tips and
overthrows just grabbing pics out of the
air and a lot of times these young
rookies they they're so used to having
success in college they feel like they
can come to the pros and make those same
throws they don't understand the speed
of these guys these guys are getting
paid a lot of money to stop him and i
know he'll know next time
not to play with belichick's defense it
robbed my guy joe burrow he's got this
brand new mouth full of teeth i hate to
blow up a spot like that but he's got
this brand new mouthful of teeth great
week one everything looks like it's
going perfect there in cincinnati he's
gonna go play the chicago bears andy
dalton the bengals old quarterback his
job what happened it wasn't good i mean
you think about at one point in time he
threw the ball three times and he threw
three interceptions and i'm sitting
there looking at you like what's wrong
with joe mixon you're from cincinnati
why won't they commit to running the
football they're playing joe mixon a lot
of money they have to run the football
he's going to be a good quarterback
he'll learn from this they got a lot of
weapons but at the end of the day
sometimes if you're if your quarterback
is off a little bit you got to run the
football and do something different
coach
micah parsons
he was making a name for himself playing
linebacker quickly in dallas they gave
him a new job today what was it he was
outstanding it's hard enough to come in
as a rookie and play and start at middle
linebacker but then they moved him to
the left side where demarcus lawrence he
got hurt so they're playing him at
defense end he was outstanding today
constant pressure on the quarterback he
got a sack and he just showed his
versatility but he definitely did his
job you think about how difficult it is
to learn middle linebacker and to move
the second week of the season and go to
defensive end and make an impact he
should be getting 100 million i want to
take this thing to l.a right now kenny
young he got fired up for the rams over
there on the gold line
his job what was it on this play what
should he have done what ended up
happening yeah he wasn't smart and when
you're in a situation like that and you
got aaron donald you got your teammates
telling you to calm down that's what you
have to do you have to calm down and you
see him yelling and screaming at the
officials they throwing flags he bumps
the official you cannot put yourself in
a situation or your team in that
situation bumping a rep you got to show
more discipline and more restraint
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports